hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my Gotham episode 9 video we got to
see a new comic book character flamingo
and we saw Missy from Doctor Who
Alfred is also turning into a bit of a
Batman himself so let's get going just
careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
the episode yet starting with top 5 WTF
number 5 meet the flamingos so this is a
character that showed up in Batman
tissues 666 imagine that he is a
cannibal in the comics just like he was
on the TV show and like a lot of
Batman's weirdest characters he was
created by Grant Morrison as part of the
circus of strange if you remember like
you know like Professor Pig they debuted
for the first time when Grant Morrison
started writing the Damian Wayne Batman
and Robin title if you never read that
issue of Batman or you've never read the
original Batman and Robin run just in
Grant Morrison fashion they are
spectacularly horrible villains I think
the TV show just decided to pull him out
of the comics just because he would push
Gordon to the edge so Guardian could
regret not killing him that was a pretty
fun moment especially when Barnes told
him the story about how he blew
someone's head off it's just next thing
I knew his head was blown clean off as
at the end of the episode flamingoes
still alive so they can still totally
use them in a future episode like oh man
I definitely should have blown that
dudes head off on the number 4 though
Jerome is dead but not forgotten so at
the beginning of the episode as we learn
about Theo being locked up we also see
the Joker graffiti that just like slowly
teasing the movement across the city the
Jerome Joker a little bit of a match in
the city not expecting any Joker's to
rise up for the rest of this season if
Hugo Strange coming so I think he's
going to be one of the biggest villains
of the season in addition to the order
of st. Dumas for speaking of villains on
to number three meet Missy newest Batman
villain of course the master would be a
Batman villain if you guys don't watch
Doctor Who this is Michelle Gomez she
plays a female version of one of the
most famous Doctor Who villains of all
time the master she just she's called
the mistress now but the character she's
playing on Gotham is not someone from
the comic book so just an original
creation of the show I did like the
speakeasy vibe tigress goes in gives the
secret password gets into the secret bar
hires the assassins thematically Gotham
is a lot like New York if you've ever
been to New York there's still a lot of
speakeasy bars I'm sure in a lot of big
cities in the United States if you've
never been to any see
bars in the United States during the
Prohibition era speakeasies rose up as
secret bars where you give a password
you get into a secret room where they
would serve alcohol when it was illegal
to do so nowadays speakeasies are just
like a really fun throwback to that just
like oh hey you know come into this
secret bar but it's not a party without
entertainment so on to my number two WTF
moment the Riddler helps the penguin get
his mojo back his murderer mojo I feel
like we're all in agreement that this is
one of the most fun pairings on the show
it's a shame that it took him this long
to get to it but the Riddler had to come
around on his ark so now he is
full-blown Riddler just without the
costume it's gonna be like a symbiotic
criminal relationship whereby the
penguin is gonna help organize the
Riddler
like the penguin has already headed his
own evil organization The Riddler hasn't
done any of that yet the penguin is like
the full-scale version of the Riddler
he's gonna teach the Riddler how to
build resources around himself
I'm really happy they're through this
penguins mother arc just because
everything the Riddler said was
completely true it was a huge crutch for
that character now that she's gone he
has nothing left to lose he could be
full-blown diabolical comic book penguin
but of course on my number one WTF the
order of st. amant arrives in Gotham
killing the guard was a little on the
nose but I did like the imagery in the
background where they had the clouds
covering the moon and you have Blackgate
prison off in the distance
Bruce's scenes really didn't crack my
top five this week but Alfred was
totally on point and I love Catwoman's
entrance at the end like everybody
around Bruce Wayne is out batmanning him
and it seems like based on her demeanor
she's like completely shaken off like
all that shade she got from silver st.
cloud my only frustration with that
whole storyline is that Bruce still
thinks silver is his friend like he
knows the he needs to get information
from her but Alfred is like look you
just have absolutely no idea what's
going on so I'm gonna stop you in your
tracks right here but just in terms of
comic book Easter eggs at the end there
was a three one three on the docks
they're like the sign the only reference
I could find to that was a two-face
story two-face is in next week's episode
so that might be acted to that but other
than the Flamingo in the order of st.
Dumas there weren't a whole bunch of big
comic book Easter eggs in this let me
know in the comments though what was
your favorite moment from the episode
and how crazy do you think that
Nathaniel Barnes is now that he told
that story about blowing that prisoners
head off when he said
there is no line to Gordon he's
basically putting himself forward like
Judge Dredd he's telling Gordon that
it's okay to go dark when you need to
but just to hype you guys on Hugo
Strange a bit BD Wong has been posting
behind the scenes pictures of his
costume transformation they've been
trying out a couple different versions
of the beard whenever he comes on it is
gonna be absolutely fantastic if you
guys didn't see him he was on mr. robot
this year it's a really awesome
character he was in Jurassic world so
he's gonna be awesome when he comes on
Gotham I don't know which episode
exactly he's gonna debut and it might
end up being the second half of the
season or might be like the mid-season
finale just in case you guys didn't know
Gorilla Grodd is coming back on the
flash tonight I've already done a
trailer video kind of explaining what's
going on with the episode it's kind of
like a King Kong allegory you can click
here to learn all about that and you can
click here to learn all about the
Captain America Civil War post-credits
scene during ant-man thank you so much
for watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight
you